>> Sean: SO THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA ECHO CHAMBER.
TRYING TO TAKE DOWN THE CIA
HER NAME IS GINA HASPEL.
A CAREER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER WHO HAS BEEN PRAISED
BY COLLEAGUES FOR HER VERY
IMPORTANT WORK AFTER 9/11
AND SHE WOULD BE THE FIRST
WOMAN TO SERVE AS THE CIA
DIRECTOR IF CONFIRMED.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA,
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS THEY SEEM
ONLY INTERESTED IN SMEARING
THE LONG SERVING
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL
PRO-PUBLIC CAN A WAS
RECENTLY FORCED TO ISSUE A
CORRECTION OF IS ACCUSING
GINA HASPEL BEING
WATERBOARDING ABU ZABO
WATERBOARDING ABU ZUBO
WATERBOARDING ABU ZUBAYDAH.
MULTIPLE STORIES ECHOED ON
MULTIPLE OUTLETS INCLUDING
FAKE NEWS CNN.
SOME ARE DENIGRATING
HASPEL'S ACHIEVEMENT AS A
WOMAN.
CALLING HER SELECTION QUOTE
AS NOT A FEMINIST CHOICE.
"NEW YORK TIMES" PUBLISHED
MODE GINA HASPEL'S RISE IS
NO VICTORY FOR FEMINISM.
WOW, HERE WITH REACTION, FOX
NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT
SEBASTIAN GORKA AND FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SEAN SPICER.
I CAN'T BELIEVE DHAWF TO BE
A LIBERAL WOMAN, DR. GORKA.
IS THAT WHAT IT IS?
IN ORDER TO ADVANCE WOMEN'S
RIGHTS, YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE
IN CERTAIN FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUES OR THIS DOES NOT
ADVANCE FEMINISM.
AND THEN I HEARD HILLARY
THIS WEEK SAY OH, THE REASON
I LOST IS BECAUSE WHITE
WOMEN LISTEN TO THEIR
HUSBANDS TO THEIR BOSSES AND
THEIR SONS BEFORE VOTING FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> LET'S JUST PUT TO THE
SIDE FOR A MOMENT, SEAN, THE
HILLARY CLINTON INSULTING
30 MILLION AMERICAN CITIZENS
TO JUST HAPPEN TO BE WOMEN
AND THEN ASK A VERY SIMPLE
QUESTION.
WHAT HAS CATCHING TERRORISTS
UNDERMINING THE ENEMIES OF
THE UNITED STATES AND BEING
A PROFESSIONAL INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER GOT TO DO WITH
FEMINISM?
WE DON'T RUN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY BASED
UPON IDEOLOGY.
THAT WAS JOHN BRENNAN.
THAT WAS UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
WE NEED TO KNOW ONE THING
ABOUT THIS WOMAN AND IT'S
CLEAR THAT SHE HAS IT IS
WHETHER OR NOT SHE IS
QUALIFIED TO BE ONE OF THE
MOST POWERFUL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS IN THE MOST
POWERFUL NATION IN THE
WORLD.
THE ONLY PROBLEM WITH THIS
WOMAN WOMAN IS, SEAN, IT'S
VERY SIMPLE.
SHE'S A WOMAN WHO IS WORKING
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S THE ONLY PROBLEM.
>> Sean: BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
WORSE THAN THAT SEAN, WE
LOST THOUSAND AMERICANS ON
9/11, 2001.
THERE WAS ONLY THREE PEOPLE
WATERBOARDED IN THE CASE OF
KHALID SHEIKH MOHAMMED IT
LED TO THE COURIER.
THE CURE YEAR LED TO BIN
LADEN.
WITHOUT WATERBOARDING THERE
IS NO.
WHAT PART DO THEY DISAGREE
WITH WE ARE TOO TOUGH ON
TERRORISTS?
THAT'S WHY THEY DON'T WANT
HER?
>> I THINK DR. GORKA IS
RIGHT ON THIS.
IF SHE WAS WORKING FOR
BARACK OBAMA, THEY WOULD
CALL HER IMMINENTLY
QUALIFIED.
LET'S LOOK AT WHO IS CALLING
HER QUALIFIED?
LEON PANETTA, HAYDEN,
MORELL, ALL OF THESE FOLKS
THAT ARE SORT OF AT THE TOP
ECHELON OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY IN A BIPARTISAN
DEGREE, ONE ADMINISTRATION
OVER THE NEXT, ALL SUPPORT
HER BECAUSE SHE IS
IMMINENTLY QUALIFIED WITH
OVER 30 YEARS EXPERIENCE.
TO YOUR POINT, SEAN, HERE'S
THE THING.
IF YOU DON'T FIFTH THE
CATEGORY THAT LIBERALS THINK
YOU ARE IN DEPENDING ON YOUR
RACE OR GENDER THEN YOU
DON'T COUNT.
GINA IS NOT QUALIFIED TO BE
CIA DIRECTOR BECAUSE SHE IS
NOT A LIBERAL.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
QUESTIONED AMERICAN BRIDGE
ASSAULTED AND WAS ARRESTED A
MALE STAFF FOR THEM
ATTACKING A FEMALE MEMBER OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
AND DID YOU SEE ANY COVERAGE
OF IT TODAY?
NO, NO, SIR IN THE "THE
WASHINGTON POST."
NOTHING IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
THERE WAS A MAN ARRESTED FOR
ASSAULTING A FEMALE MEMBER.
AND DR. GORKA IS RIGHT.
WHY?
BECAUSE SHE WORKS FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
IF THIS HAD BEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN LEADING THE
EVENING NEWS TODAY.
THE HYPOCRISY AND DOUBLE
STANDARD IS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Sean: I JUST REALLY -- WE
LOOK AT THESE TIMES YOU
HAVE, DR. GORKA, THIS CANNOT
BE EMPHASIZED ENOUGH.
THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
SCANDAL IN THE HILLS
INDUSTRY OF THE COUNTRY.
IT'S LITERALLY SITTING RIGHT
THERE ON A TEE FOR THE
MEDIA.
THE MEDIA ALL THEY CARE
ABOUT IS STORMY DANIELS AND
RUSSIA-TRUMP COLLUSION AND
AFTER, WHAT, ALMOST 18
MONTHS WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE.
THIS IS ALL THAT THEY COVER.
IT'S AMAZING THAT HERE WITH
ALL THE EVIDENCE WE HAVE
HILLARY FIXES A PRIMARY.
HILLARY HAS CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY THAT IS FIXED FOR
HER.
SHE PURCHASES LIES AND A
PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER, LIE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S USED TO OBTAIN FISA
WARRANT AND, OF COURSE, THEY
DON'T TELL THE FISA JUDGE
THAT HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR IT SO WE CAN SPY ON
OPPOSITION PARTY CANDIDATE
AND CAMPAIGN.
HOW ABOUT COVERING REAL NEWS
FOR ONCE.
>> WELL, LOOK, THAT'S NOT
THEIR JOB.
THESE ARE PROPAGANDISTS.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE FISA
GATE SCANDAL, WHAT WE HAVE
IS HILLARY CLINTON, THE DNC
AFFECTING A SUCCESSFUL
RUSSIAN OPERATION BECAUSE
THAT FILE WAS FULL OF
RUSSIAN MISINFORMATION.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THESE PEOPLE AREN'T
INTERESTED IN THE TRUTH.
THIS IS PERHAPS THE BIGGEST
SCANDAL THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
A POLITICAL ELECTION SINCE
1776.
AND LET'S JUST REMEMBER ONE
THING, SEAN, IF SHE HAD WON,
WE WOULDN'T KNOW ANY OF IT,
NONE OF IT.
NOT FISA GATE, NOT URANIUM
ONE.
IT WOULD HAVE ALL BEEN
COVERED UP.
AND THAT'S THE SCARY THING.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
SEAN SPICER.
>> HAVE YOU GREAT ECONOMIC
NEWS TODAY IF IT WASN'T FOR
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING TOUT
TO HIS FOLLOWERS WE WOULDN'T
KNOW ABOUT IT NOT WHETHER
ONE STAFF COULD OR SHOULD BE
FIRED BY THE END OF THE
WEEK.
MORE TIME SPENT WHETHER OR
NOT SOMEBODY IS ACTUALLY IN
THE OFFICE TODAY.
THE WHITE HOUSE POOL SENT
OUT A REPORT TODAY THAT THEY
CITED H.R. McMASTER THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
MEANTIME THE ECONOMY
CONTINUES TO HUM ALONG AND
PEOPLE ARE LIVING BETTER
LIVES IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
UNBELIEVABLE.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DID
YOUR JOB.
I WOULD HAVE EXPLODED.
I COULDN'T DO IT.
WHAT YOU AND SARAH HUCKABEE